monter une boîte
certains parmi vous l'ont déjà fait
d'autres le feront sans doute
moi j'ai monté une boîte et ça m'a amené
à des endroits incroyables
j'aurais jamais cru aller par exemple
ici ce soir j'aurais jamais cru faire un
ted un jour et pourtant et pourtant des
gens m'invitent pour que je vienne
parler de ma boîte
alors ma boîte je vous la présenter la
voilà voici ma boîte
cette boîte est une révolution
alors j'ai c'est un mec vous a fait le
coup il ya dix ans avec un téléphone oui
c'est une révolution pour une certaine
catégorie de personnes peut-être pas
pour tout le monde ici mais en tout cas
pour les scientifiques de mon
laboratoire
c'est vraiment une révolution comme vous
le voyez cette boîte je vais la tournée
vers vous c'est pas juste une simple
boîte il ya dessus une carte
électronique que vous voyez là et cette
carte électronique c'est un raspberry pi
on l'appelle la framboise cet ordinateur
il a deux caractéristiques intéressantes
d'abord il est pas cher coûte 35 euros
ça va pour un ordi le deuxième trou
qu'intéressant c'est qu'on peut brancher
plein de choses dessus et c'est facile à
utiliser c'est vraiment très facile
d'ailleurs moi j ai brancher un écran un
petit écran des boutons et puis une
imprimante à tickets de caisse alors
vous vous dites
bon rien d'exceptionnel quoi
si ce qui est exceptionnel c'est pas
l'extérieur ça veut dire que c'est
l'intérieur sauf que comme vous le voyez
à l'intérieur de la boîte
en gros il ya des files d'accord si
parmi vous parmi vous des gens qui ont
des enfants qui sont au collège et c'est
pire puisque christelle a demandé tout à
l'heure en techno ils font des trucs
mais dix fois mieux que ça c'est là que
moi j'ai pas soudé depuis ma troisième
quoi donc j'ai réappris
donc cette boîte elle ne vous fait pas
peur et ça c'est très important pour
bien comprendre pourquoi j'ai créé cette
boîte
il faut revenir quelques années en
arrière
neuf ans il y a neuf ans je rentre en
première année de doctorat
je vais préparer une thèse waouh je suis
fier mes parents aussi
par contre dans les repas de famille
quand une cousine un cousin un oncle une
tante me demande alors qu'est ce tu fais
alors je lui réponds je lui dis que je
développe un programme pour faire de
l'alignement locales pour la
reconnaissance de repliement des
protéines par programmation linéaire en
nombre entier c'est le vrai titre de ma
thèse est là il ya un froid et puis
j'essaie d'expliquer voilà et mais je
suis en première année de thèse je sais
pas expliquer alors c'est long ça
ennuyeux
et puis là il ya un truc qui me frustre
c'est que j'arrive pas à faire passer
aux gens pourquoi la science ça me
passionne parce que j'adore ça j'adore
ça c'est la chasse au trésor on sent
carte au début sans peine si on finit
par tout une carte une pelle on commence
à creuser on tombe sur rien qui ont
recreusé à côté on retombe sur rien etc
etc
mais c'est passionnant et j'arrive pas à
le faire passer et ça ça me frustre
beaucoup alors je vais commencer à
regarder comment font les autres
scientifiques les autres chercheurs pour
expliquer la science est un truc à faire
c'est pas sorcier
et oui c'est pas sorcier il utilise des
images des métaphores
il enlève tout le jargon scientifique
ils remettent un petit peu et ça marche
un exemple imaginer un livre vous avez
tous un livre en tête à ses pairs pas
juste un poche sur la couverture il n'y
a rien d'écrit
ça va vous l'avez tous et en plus nous
ne pouvait pas l'ouvrir mais vous savez
qu'il ya quelque chose d'écrit sur les
pages le seul moyen que vous avez pour
lire ce livre c'est le mettre dans une
machine qui va ouvrir le livre est
découpé chaque page en fines bandelettes
au hasard vous obtenez çà et là vous
pouvez lire le livre si vous avez du
temps et quelques kilos de scotch
figurez vous que ça c'est ce qui se
passe pour l'adn l'adn c'est une
molécule que tous les êtres vivants ont
dans leur cellule et qui définit leur
fonctionnement ça définit comment ils
survivent
qu'est ce qui est bénéfique pour eux
qu'est ce qui les tue ça définit toutes
les toutes les réactions chimiques qui
se passe dans leur cellule
quand des chercheurs veulent comprendre
comment fonctionne un organisme un être
vivant
une des premières choses qu'ils peuvent
faire aujourd'hui c'est séquencer l'adn
et le lire problème c'est que on peut
pas prendre des cellules d'un être
vivant ouvrir la cellule élire l'adn pas
possible on est obligé avec des produits
chimiques de le casser en petits
morceaux et de recomposer le puzzle vous
imaginez bien que les scientifiques du
monde entier ne passent pas leur temps à
aligner des petits bouts de bandelettes
d'adr d'accord on le fait par ordinateur
ceci dit même pour un ordinateur c'est
extrêmement compliqué de ré assembler le
puzzle de l'adn pour vous donner une
idée pour assembler le génome humain
le génome humain c'est 3,4 milliards de
lettres
pour le ré assembler en gros il vous
faut une centaine d'ordinateurs et 24
heures de calcul
voilà avec des images avec une métaphore
j'arrive à vous faire passer des notions
scientifiques un peu complexe mais sans
rentrer dans les détails je finis ma
thèse et je pars en région parisienne
pour un contrat de deux ans pour
continuer à faire de la recherche
et pendant que je suis à paris je
découvre un mouvement qui s'appelle les
maker les meilleurs vous en avais plein
dans les ateliers
c'est les gens qui travaillent dans des
fab lab enfin qui travaillent qui
s'amusent dans des fab lab et qui
apprennent et qui apprennent et qui
apprennent des tas de nouvelles choses
justes en allant et en faisant quelque
chose de leurs mains et ça ça me parle
parce que quand j'étais plus jeune
j'étais formateur bafa pour une
association
et là bas j'ai appris que on apprend
bien quand on fait avec ses mains et je
garde ça en tête
je garde ça en tête et là se passe un
événement enfin deux événements qui
arrivent à peu près en même temps
j'achète une framboise pour noël parce
que je suis un peu geek et puis je
retourne dans le laboratoire où j'avais
passé ma thèse et là je retrouve deux
anciens collègues qui était en tête avec
moi et qui travaille sur un sujet
vachement intéressant c'est l'assemblage
de génomes l'assemblage de génomes que
je viens de vous expliquer l'assemblage
le génome sans ordinateur qui calcule
pendant 24 heures et moi j'arrive au
labo ils disent et guillaume on est les
premiers au monde à avoir rassemblé le
génome humain sur un macbook
vous imaginez la révolution que c'est
chez les scientifiques au lieu
d'assemblée un génome sur son ordinateur
on va assembler sans génome sur son
ordinateur c'est une énorme invention
elle est due à deux jeunes et brillants
chercheurs qui sont dans la salle tout à
l'heure rester dans le fond là bas qui
s'appelle ryan chicchi et guillaume
risque et je vous demande de les
applaudir
alors moi je suis avec mon raspberry pi
je le redis c'est génial les gars vous
croyez que ça passe là dessus m 10 non
non mais je dis pas le génome humain
d'accord le génome humain ça va pas
passer ok mais des génomes plus petits
genre des bactéries des champignons des
trucs où il n'y a pas trop de l'adn
faudrait tester leur dis bah donnez-moi
le code 2d mois le programme
informatique je vais tester et je teste
et magie de la science ça marche pas
alors je retourne voir l'autre guillaume
je dis bah ça marche pas je comprends
pas parce que c'est un petit génome ça
devrait passer
et puis je vais regarder et puis il
améliore le programme il améliore le
programme et ça passe on arrive à
assembler le génome de la levure la
levure pour faire le pingouin puis
gibbard on passe à un génome au dessus
alors de nouveau on a des problèmes puis
on y arrive et puis là on se dit bon
nous faudrait quelque chose d'un peu
plus gros mais pas trop mais qui ait du
sens là je lui dis ben l'ordinateur
c'est une framboise à son blond le
génome de la framboise et du coup on a
été les premiers au monde à assembler le
génome de la framboise sur un raspberry
pi
et là vous commencez à voir où je veux
en venir avec ma boîte parce que ça ces
deux événements donc moi qui arrive avec
le raspberry pi est eux qui ont inventé
un logiciel capable d'assembler des
génomes avec des petits ordinateurs et
ben on va se mettre ensemble et on va
créer cette boîte
pourquoi faire une boîte bas pour aller
voir les autres scientifiques et leur
expliquer et oui ça marche parce qu'un
scientifique quand il fait une
découverte qui va faire un papier
scientifique avec plein de formules
beaucoup de textes ils valent publié
dans un journal scientifique qui est
fait pour les scientifiques
mais après le retour il est pas si
énorme que ça revient pas faire un tête
quoi par contre en faisant une boîte on
peut prendre la boîte aller devant les
scientifiques donc nous on est allé à la
conférence française bioinformatique on
est venu avec notre boîte on avait
préparé un petit posters scientifiques
qui expliquait les choses comme dans un
article scientifique et là j'ai vu des
chercheurs des vieux chercheurs de mes
anciens profs qu'il n'aille qui ne dit
c'est vous qui avez la boîte qui
assemble des génomes et après on a un
ticket de caisse avec un bout de génomes
dessus bah ouais venez et on a gagné le
prix du meilleur poster
hornain on a un peu triché on avait mis
un pot de miel à côté du poster
forcément il venait quand il est attiré
mais ce qui est génial et ce à quoi je
m'attendais pas c'est que cette boîte
j'ai conçu de façon à ce que je puisse
l'expliquer a en gros un gamin de 12 ans
et puis qu'il ait pas peur de venir
devenir la touche et devenir la
manipuler et puis en plus je les fait
accessible c'est à dire que tous les
plans sont sur internet via le fab lab
de rennes et tous les plans pour refaire
la boîte vous pouvez le faire si vous
voulez le code informatique il est
accessible vous pouvez y aller les open
source et ça c'est très important parce
que du coup des collègues de nantes ont
demandé s'il faut alors prêté la boîte
pour aller devant des lycéens et leur
expliquer ce que c'est l assemblage de
génome du pou y sont allés et il ya une
centaine plus d'une centaine de lycéens
qui ont joué avec cette boîte et puis
une chose en entraînant une autre
on m'a proposé de parler à la communauté
des maker et de l'open source
et puisque tout est ouvert et encore une
fois les gens sont venus ils ont joué et
là même les gars ils m'ont dit ton truc
c'est disruptif j'avais parce que
c'était destructif jardy ah bon il se
marre oui parce que les scientifiques
qui viennent pas dans les fab lab et toi
tu fais un truc dans son laboratoire
mais comme si c'était un fab lab moi si
ça vous touche c'est cool
c'est là que j'ai filé les plans aux fab
lab et puis bah j'ai croisé d'autres
gens et je me suis retrouvé invité à la
french tech de rennes et la ministre
déléguée au numérique a joué avec la
boîte et elle a son petit ticket de
caisse avec un bouddha dn2 su
reconstituer tout ça pour vous dire que
grâce à cette boîte j'ai touché tous les
publics même vous aujourd'hui il ya un
truc bizarre qui se passe avec cette
boîte d'ailleurs un virus un truc parce
qu'en fait j'ai contaminer des gens
depuis quelques mois je suis directeur
pédagogique adjoint dans une école
supérieure d'informatique
il se trouve que bizarrement depuis que
je suis arrivé mes étudiants ont
commencé à fabriquer des boîtes
pour de vrai la boîte à gauche là elle
est dans le stand maisons mikit maisons
mix des ateliers et l'autre boîte que au
poignet là je peux pas vous en parler
parce que c'est un projet secret de mes
étudiants déjà
déjà je la montre vas-y coupe donc que
vous soyez scientifique ou pas
scientifique
j'espère ce soir vous avoir transmis le
virus
et j'espère que tous en rentrant vous
aurez envie de monter une boîte
merci